alors ça c'est ça je voulais vous en
parle absolument aujourd'hui au dessus
d'un célèbre centre commercial parisien
une publicité a fait énormément
polémique une marque de lingerie montré
un fessier sont sous vêtements
sous-vêtements
alors c'est là on va lire la news voilà
c'est la fameuse marque de lingerie
ce qui commence pas au qui finit par la
bad et vous allez nous dire si cette
polémique elle vous choque vous a fait
un récapitulatif de l'histoire en garde
à l'approché des fêtes de noël les
galeries lafayette célèbre magasin du
centre de paris est un endroit où se
pressent des milliers de personnes pour
faire leurs achats
un endroit aussi célèbre pour ses
vitrines de noël qui attire chaque jour
de nombreuses familles et ces derniers
temps c'est une publicité affichée sur
la devanture de cette célèbre enseigne
et qui a fait polémique
la marque de lingerie aubade décidé de
faire la promotion de sa gamme de
sous-vêtements en se payant une campagne
de publicité sur laquelle on peut voir
la photo d'un mannequin en culotte de
dos reprenant le célèbre visuelle des
années 80 de la marque
une initiative qui a choqué quelques
passants mais surtout fait bondir l'élue
parisienne hélène bidard il faut dire
qu'à la mairie de paris elle est
adjointe chargée de l'égalité femmes
hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations et des droits humains
sur twitter l'élu s'est exprimée
sérieusement les galeries lafayette en
en pleine vague mais tout est à quelques
jours de noël vous n'avez rien de mieux
à afficher que les fesses d'une femme
sans visage
je demande le retrait immédiat de cette
campagne sexistes et ce coup de gueule
aura suffit à lui seul à faire plier la
direction des galeries lafayette qui a
décidé en seulement quelques heures de
retirer la fiche et de la remplacer par
celle d'un parfum d'une autre marque
je vous demande chez vous détendre et
qui les 21,22 fallait-il retirer cette
affiche
alors non non non non non la gym qui dit
oui parce qu'une fois gilbert den haag
m6 s'est mis en mode production c'est à
dire un truc est très sincère il
n'aurait pas autant de fans je quitterai
ce pays je ne peux plus alors je vais
faire un appel aux fans étaient là mais
on tient peut-être un truc c'est grave
ce qui se passe en 2018 et pendant
gilles à cause de gens comme toi où il
c'est grave ce qui se passera si elle a
des très jolies fesses et un mannequin
au nom de ses fesses
so what sur les suisses calvin klein
quand vous achetez un slip pour les
garçons c'est toujours des mecs qui ont
des tablettes en vol ce qui pour moi
vois c'est magnifique nouvelle du bo
pour du blond c'est magnifique ce
esthétique
enfin m quoiqu'elle mais quelqu'un qu'on
va leur mordant on écoutera les plus
aimés j'enlève le banc oui mais tout le
monde a attendu la phase suivante de la
paix tout le monde trouvait ça génial et
brusquement à bart staes est plus
pudique
ça vous a pas choqué vous mais
évidemment que ça va aller mal et qu'il
y aurait vu un oui mais vous avez dit je
vous ai vue de trouver les mêmes juste
francesca ou oui alors moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en train de
rentrer dans un espèce de féminisme
exacerbé et que là maintenant on subit
le féminisme moi je suis une femme jaoui
bien bon ouais depuis peu merci à l'éval
pas les bottes à l'est aussi
je pense que au contraire il faut qu'on
se bat pour qu'on puisse continuer à
voir ce genre de publicité moi ça me
fait plaisir de voir des jolies fesses
sur la devanture d'un grand magasin et
je trouve qu'il faut se battre pour
garder ça elle c'est une élue elle veut
faire bien on est après le mouvement mis
tout mais franchement là elle me casse
les bonbons tu veux toi j'ai envie de
continuer à voir cette pub
s'il vous plaît vous oui parce qu'elle
est restée crochée correct c'est juste
que cette campagne elle existe depuis
1990 et là il aurait il se chante
maintenant est bon moi ça me choque pas
parce que c'est une manière de liberté
on est content ou en été quand les
jolies filles se mettent en robe on est
content c'est une manière de lâcher
il fallait on est content quand les
garçons se mettent on est content quand
les cartes sont bien d'autres santé je
veux juste rappeler à hélène bidard qui
est dans le 9e arrondissement de paris
pour expliquer aux gens ça c'est à 200
mètres de pigalle tout le monde connait
pyatt avait pas choqué par pigalle et
choqué par ça alors fait d'études sur
pia et après qu'il sera détruite sur ton
en fait les tweets sur pia c'est paris
pas là de la dent il participe alors
c'est pigalle la blanche
la lamelle alors il y en a qui est très
calme très calme mais très choqué et je
trouve que les propos tenus ici sont
indignés je voulais vous le dire serrer
le minimum non alors à vous voulez vous
voulez que je prenne des sanctions
vous pouvez oui ce serait un plaisir un
régal
si vous pouvez virer tous ces connards
avait pas de vous n'avez pas dit des
bêtises dans votre argent oui je précède
pour gilles que d'arcy pensent comme
nous ils viennent me le dira non à du
groupe en mars mais les passages
franchement réduire les femmes à une
paire de fesses parce qu'il s'agit de
terroristes ou du cul
[Applaudissements]
pour la lingerie ne va pas mettre des
photos de genre de gens de les leur
c'est justement son gagne-pain
émergentes de quel droit tu va
l'empêcher de gagner sa vie et là c'est
vous on m'empêche de m'exprimer sac et
honteux alors allez-y
alors on réduit les femmes à une paire
de fesses si on avait montré le corps
entier on aurait pu discuter mais ça
c'est du sexisme c'est dégradant pour
l'image de la ferrari on est assez mais
arrêtez c'est pas parce que c'est une
pub pour la linge et la cour doit
montrer sa une
[Rires]
un voyage est long dans le monde dont le
monde absurde de gilles salue l'homme
l'a utilisé pas instrumentaliser cette
photo moi je suis une femme j'ai pas
droit de trouver ça beau et excitant
virage suis d'accord note pour plaire à
mon quartier tout le monde aime ça c'est
abstinent matière devant nous des gens
sont choqués néanmoins il faut ruser
[Applaudissements]
voilà eu des pulls il ya eu des pubs
avec des garçons en slip et bélie tous
les as qu on les a mais bien le visage
ces mecs là moi je commence à pas la
même chose mais non parce qu'on montre
le visage mais à l'hosto cbk alors que
l'autre c'est une paire de fesses mais
réduire la femme à ça et c'est ont
toujours été comme ça c'est fait grâce à
100 les grands magasins j'ai fait le jeu
des extrémistes